hi everyone welcome to the first
photography technique tutorial of the
MIT museum's Imaging Science program my
name is Brian Roth I am the education
coordinator here at the Museum and here
to go through some techniques and
settings and things that you can use to
take advantage of your camera to make
some great science photography the
techniques that we're going to talk
about will apply to all different types
of cameras so whether you're taking
pictures on a cell phone or a
point-and-shoot or a DSLR or mirrorless
we're going to cover techniques that
work for all of these that don't require
any specialized equipment except for the
the camera that you have in front of you
so with that we're gonna get started in
this tutorial and go over some of the
basic settings of your camera and how
they work
so to start cameras today I'm digital
cameras have the center so what does the
sensor do in the camera the sensor is
basically a photon counter it just tells
you how much light is going to enter the
camera while you're taking the picture I
mentioned photons photons are the way
we're going to model light when talking
about digital photography so we think
about light coming from a source or a
picture so let's say I'm going to take a
picture of a person here
what's so here's the person I want to
take a picture of and there's gonna be
light bouncing off that person and we're
gonna imagine that that light is
bouncing off that person and coming
towards the camera center as these
little pieces little particles of light
when they get to this center the center
is going to count how many pic how many
photons hit the center in a certain
place and that's going to create our
image so you may have heard of
megapixels when looking at different
cameras different cameras have different
numbers of megapixels and all that
number means is how many
spot roughly you have on your sensor to
measure photons so how many little
places there are and so if we zoom in on
the center you can start seeing what are
called photo sites that come together to
make pixels on this sensor now for the
techniques that we're going to be using
throughout this tutorial series the only
requirement is that you have a camera
and that that camera can change settings
those settings are the shutter speed
often represented with a fraction of a
second that ISO which is a number
usually between 100 and 10,000 but it
can go on either end of that and the
aperture most DSLRs and point-and-shoot
should have this functionality built in
you may have to go to a mode called
manual on a cell phone some phones have
the ability to change these settings
just out of the box they have their apps
are able to sometimes you need to
download a different app that will give
you access to these settings the one
thing to note about whatever app you use
if you're going to use a cell phone you
cannot adjust aperture on a cell phone
now that you have the ability to change
your camera settings we're going to talk
about what all of these do and
essentially all of these control how
much light enters your camera the more
of those photons those little pieces of
light that reach your sensor the
brighter your image is going to be and
so we have three different ways this is
often called the exposure triangle to
adjust this amount of light we have ISO
aperture and shutter and well why do we
have three different ways to do the same
thing each one has a secondary effect on
the image so they don't just change the
brightness of the image they change
something else about the image that
we're going to explore so the first
setting we're going to take a dive into
is the shutter speed now the shutter is
a piece of thin material it's kind of
like a
vinyl plastic material that can open and
close and either let light in or block
light from hitting the center of your
camera so let's see how this works the
shutter speed is measured in fractions
of a second so for example if we had a
shutter speed of 1 over 30 that means
that the shutter is open letting photons
into the center for one thirtieth of a
second and you can have shutter speeds
usually ranging between 30 seconds and
1/8 thousandths of a second on many
cameras and some cameras can go even
longer or shorter the longer the shutter
speed the more photons enter your camera
and the brighter your image is going to
be the shorter your shutter speed the
fewer photons are going to enter your
camera and the darker the image is going
to be if you're taking a picture with a
cell phone it doesn't have a mechanical
shutter it doesn't have these pieces of
plastic that move in front of the center
it's too small and so what a cell phone
will do is in order to take a picture
with a cell phone you need to be able to
see the image before you take it there's
a live feed you can see the light coming
in to the camera but in order for you to
see a live picture before you take the
pictures you can see what you're trying
to image you need to capture photons and
compute do computations on that data and
put it on the screen very quickly the
camera is not fast enough the cell phone
is not fast enough to do that all at
once so what the cell phone actually
does is it scans and it's going to scan
line by line so it's going to record the
data where this green line is and it's
gonna start displaying it as it scans
the next line and it's going to scan and
display scan and display and it's gonna
go like this and just like the the DSLR
the faster this happens the less light
your camera records if you have a slow
shutter speed it's gonna record light
for a longer period of time on each line
of that center and you're going to get a
brighter image so what can you do with
shutter speed that sets it apart from
the other ways of controlling how much
light enters your camera what we're
trying to make observations during this
program right an imaging science so let
me show you what you can do so for
example on the left side of the screen
these two images here were taken with a
fast shutter speed or in other words a
very short shutter speed may be around a
thousandth of a second this means it
freezes the motion because the can
picture was taken very quickly you can
freeze what's happening so as this car
moves across the screen here I'm able to
capture it so it looks like it's staying
still same thing with this this carnival
ride in the picture on the bottom but
you'll note is with this fast shutter
speed I don't capture much light so if
you look at this building next to next
to the ride here it's very dark so I may
want to lengthen that shutter speed so
may want to have it open for a longer
period of time and what that can do is
it'll blur your image but it'll show
motion because the cameras going to be
collecting photons while something is
moving so in the first example maybe I
want to show the motion of the car so
this is a long shutter speed this is
probably around a tenth of a second and
as the car moves across it bores so
you're capturing the car in lots of
different positions but it shows the
path really well same thing with the
carnival ride on the bottom now we can
see the motion from the first one you
may not know that this is a spinning
ride but in the second one it's very
clear because it's blurred out in this
circle that this is spinning very
quickly
you'll also notice that this building to
the side is much brighter and again
that's because we've allowed the camera
to capture more photons when that
shutter is open the next setting that
we're going to talk about is aperture
now aperture is the one setting that you
cannot control on a cell phone but on
most other cameras you do have control
of this feature the aperture is
essentially the hole that the light can
travel through in your camera so in your
in your lens you usually have these kind
of circles and this is gonna open up
different amounts depending on your
aperture setting the wider your aperture
is like the one on the left we're gonna
let more photons into your camera and
the one on the right here has a much
smaller hole so that's gonna block most
of the photons so this is going to be a
much darker image with the smaller
aperture let's see how the aperture
works
so besides controlling how much light
comes in the camera why would we use
aperture to control brightness well just
like shutter speed controlled how you
can show movement or freeze movement in
an image aperture has another ability
where it allows you to control what's
called the depth of field this is how
much is in focus when you take your
picture as you can see in these pictures
below with a wide aperture so a very
open aperture here only a small amount
of our picture is actually in focus as
we close down this aperture as we make
the hole smaller more and more of the
picture is going to be in focus and this
is going to let us do things such as
call attention to certain parts of the
image if you can control how much of it
is in focus you can highlight something
by putting it in focus and blurring out
the things that maybe aren't as
important to the image or if you want to
show if everything in the image is
important for what you're trying trying
to show then you might want to use a
smaller aperture and keep everything in
focus aperture is measured in what is
called F stocks or F numbers so the F
numbers work by set going lower numbers
so F 1 point 8 for example a low number
is a wide aperture the higher the number
such as F 32 is a smaller aperture the
reason that these numbers seem a little
bit reversed to what you may think they
should be is that they represent a ratio
between the focal length of a lens
essentially how zoomed in the lens is
and how wide the lenses so now let's
take a quick look at how the aperture
works in terms of changing the depth of
field so let's say we want to take a
picture of this puppy here and so light
is going to come from the puppy and go
to the sensor
in between that the subject and the
camera in the center is the lens so what
the lens is going to do is take parallel
lines of light that come into the camera
it's going to focus them onto what's
called a focal point so all of these
lines of light are going to cross at a
certain point but the lens can only do
this it'll only focus light to the same
point if it comes in parallel to itself
if we have light let's say that comes in
at a different angle this light is not
going to be bent to the exact same point
the aperture is going to basically
control what angle the light can enter
the camera when light doesn't come in
parallel to itself it's no longer
focusing at the same point and it's
going to be blurry so we'll remove the
lens just to make this a little bit
simpler and we'll look at the aperture
so the aperture is you said it's just
the hole that the light is going to
enter the camera through and so when we
have a small aperture like this light is
coming from our image from all different
directions here but with a small
aperture only light that is parallel or
at a very small angle is able to pass
through and get to the sensor all this
other light that's coming in from
different angles is going to get blocked
by that aperture so since all the light
coming through is parallel it's all
going to get focused to the same spot
and no matter where it came from in our
image here it's all going to come in to
the camera at the same focus so we have
an image where it has high depth of
field everything is in focus now let's
say instead we have a very wide aperture
when we have a wide aperture the light
that's going to come into the camera it
doesn't have to be parallel some of it's
going to be parallel but we're also
to allow light in that's coming from all
sorts of different angles because we're
allowing that light into the camera it's
not going to focus the same way as it
passes through the lens your cameras
only going to be able to focus on some
of this light basically light that's
only come from a certain area of this
photo so let's say we want to focus on
his nose then all of the light that's
coming in a straight line from his nose
that's gonna be able to be focused but
like coming back here from his ear
that's coming in at a slightly different
angle it's still now reaching the center
because we have a wide aperture but it's
not going to be in focus it's gonna be a
bit blurry and that's how we're gonna
get that it blurry background or
foreground or whatever you're trying to
do in your photo the third and final
setting that we're going to talk about
in our camera is what's called ISO ISO
used to be ISO standing for
international standards organization
used to be a standard measurement of
what was called film speed essentially
how sensitive was the film to light in
today's camera whether it's a cell phone
or DSLR or any digital camera it's going
to measure the sensitivity of the sensor
and it's no longer standardized so
different ISO numbers are going to match
up to different effects and we'll talk a
little bit about that in a minute
but basically the lower the ISO so let's
say we have an ISO of 100 so if we have
an ISO of 100 this is going to require a
lot more photons in order to get the
same brightness of image then if you
took a picture at 1000 ISO so you need
fewer photons to get the same brightness
in an image because the Centers it's
more sensitive to that light or it's
amplifying the light more with the
higher ISO now this sounds great
well why don't I just control how bright
my images using ISO and just like
shutter speed and aperture ISO has its
own effects on an image so if we take a
look at these images these are four
images taken with all the same settings
except for different ISOs if I put on
the labels you'll see the upper left
corner is at 100 so this is a very dark
image because there was only a few
photons coming to the camera a few
meaning millions when we're talking
about photons were talking about
millions billions of photons entering
the camera but this had a relatively
small number of photons entering the
camera so it's not a very right image if
we boost the sensitivity if we raise the
ISO to let's say a thousand you can see
the image is becoming brighter it
actually captured the same number of
photons in both images because we kept
the aperture to the same the shutter the
same so you're starting to see more
detail we keep going here's iso 5000
it's even brighter we can see a lot more
detail in the image but you're also
starting to see some graininess in the
image and this is really pronounced in
this image at ISO 10000 you can see a
lot of graininess and this is called
noise basically what this is is that
we're getting most of our photons from
the image from the same points in space
but there are some random photons that
are entering the camera and because
we're capturing very little light
remember that at ISO 100 for this image
we really can't see much so if we have a
stray photon a random photon come into
our camera we're going to detect that
because we don't have all the other
photons from our image from this
fireplace here to cancel that out
another way to say that is we have a
very low signal to noise ratio so
there's not much signal
light from the subject that we want to
take a picture of so the noise the
randomness is very easy to see where if
you use a low ISO and if you have a lot
of light a lot of light coming in the
signal-to-noise ratio is very high so
you have a lot of photons from your
subject so the relatively few photons
that are coming in from random sources
aren't going to appear so to wrap up
let's go back to our exposure triangle
and there are three settings that we can
control on a cell phone - and they're
all related to each other they all
control how much light comes into your
image so how do you decide what you're
going to do so it depends on what you're
trying to show in your photo if the
motion or the amount of motion and your
image is really important whether you
want to freeze your image you're gonna
want to pick a shutter speed that gives
you the effect you want and then adjust
the other two ISO an aperture to get the
brightness that you need if the
important part of your photo is the
depth of field so what's in focus what's
not in focus
then you're gonna set your aperture
first and then adjust the other two to
give you the correct exposure for your
image now this triangle is great and it
lets you do all sorts of really cool
things but there's one thing that's
really easy to forget in photography
even though we talked about all the time
and that's light right everything we're
talking about is how much light is
entering your camera and if you're
trying to take a photo and you're not
able to get the effect you want maybe
you want a high depth of field and you
want a fast shutter speed but your image
is getting very grainy because you have
to use a high ISO well what can you do
well how about get more light right
so you can always control the light or
in most cases control the light that's
around you so using a flashlight ceiling
lights the light from the window
cell phone light laser pointer flash
whatever you have around you use light
to copy
say what for what you want to do with
this exposure triangle now let's try a
couple of examples and just see what we
would do for camera settings now camera
settings are gonna vary for every camera
that you try to use so these are just
going to be rough estimates so for
example I want to take a picture of this
bird here so this bird it's flying in
the air so it's moving so what am I
going to prioritize so movements
involved so I'm gonna pick in this case
shutter speed so what I want to use for
this photo is a short shutter speed or
fast shutter speed so I'm going to do a
short shutter speed and that's gonna
mean my image is going to be dark so I
need to figure out well what are the
other things I can adjust well I don't
really care about the background detail
I'm taking this picture to capture the
bird so if I don't need the background
to be in focus I can use a wide aperture
or a low f-stop number and that will
blur out the background but it also give
me more light and then what that leaves
me with is the ISO and I can adjust that
to get the exposure I need based on how
much sunlight there is if there's cloud
or a bunch of other factors with the
light so again for this image short
shutter speed to capture the motion a
wide aperture to compensate for that
lack of light and then I adjusted the
ISO to get the image that I wanted so
let's look at a second example in this
example I have a close-up image of a
dime now as you move closer to your
subject one thing that you're gonna
discover is it is harder to get
everything in focus your depth of field
decreases as you move closer to the
image and that has to do with the angle
the lights entering your camera in our
next tutorial we're going to
specifically talk about close-up imaging
or macro photography um but for now if I
want to take a picture with the entire
diamond focus well which setting am I
going to focus on well I'm worried about
depth of field so it's going to be
aperture so what I want to use here is a
small aperture in order to get that
depth of field or a high f-stop number
if I'm going to have a small aperture
that means that my image is going to be
very dark because it's not letting light
in so that maybe then I'm going to
choose a long shutter speed in order to
compensate for that and then again I'm
going to adjust the ISO in order to get
the exposure I need so in this image
depth of field was the priority so I
chose the aperture and then adjusted the
other settings accordingly thank you for
joining us for this tutorial in our
imaging science series with the MIT
Museum and Koch Institute we'd love to
see your stunning science photos if
you'd like to share them with us you can
show them on Facebook Twitter and
Instagram and use the hashtag MIT em
imaging science to share those with us
at the end of this program so on June
20th will be holding a webinar to look
at what makes a great science photo and
some of those submissions have a chance
to be featured during that webinar for
more information on the imaging science
program other tutorials and other
information and resources please visit
the MIT Museum website at the link below
and you will find a list of our other
resources as part of the Imaging Science
program